The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG:
So I've mentioned
randomized linear
algebra a few times,
and I thought, OK, I'm going
to jump in and describe
randomized matrix
multiplication.
It's a pretty cool
idea, it seems to me.
So this is a topic within
randomized linear algebra.
And when would we be
doing any of this?
It would be for matrices that
are just really, really large.
So we plan to sample the
columns of A and sample
the corresponding
rows of B, so actually
that when we decide on a column,
we've also decided on a row.
So we're taking
those pieces, which
do correctly add up
to AB, but we're not
going to take them all.
We're going to take
different ones,
randomly sampled
with probabilities--
we have to decide
probabilities--
and then we'll add
up our samples,
and we hope that the
result is close to AB.
That's the idea.
OK, so this lecture then,
so I wrote these pages
about six months ago.
So I've been desperately
trying to remember
what I wrote, because it's not
a subject I have ever spoken
about before, but it's so neat.
So here are some of the
things that come into it.
We have to decide
on probabilities.
Then we want to
compute the mean.
So it's our first day with
some of these key ideas
from statistics and probability.
So we're going to take
probabilities that add to 1.
We're going to figure
out what's the mean value
of our random AB.
We hope, and we will see that
the mean value of the random AB
is correct AB.
But there will be a variance.
Every sample won't be correct.
In fact, no samples
will be correct.
Only when we add them up on
the average, they're correct,
and we get to correct AB.
So the mean will come out right.
It will come out as AB.
You'll see it happen.
Correct.
But there's a big
variance, not zero.
We'll be all over the
place with our samples.
They'll just average out
right, but they'll be all over.
No particular sample
will be right at all.
So then we want to pick
the best probabilities.
So our job will be, once we
see how the system works,
we're going to
assign probabilities.
And we're going to choose
the probabilities that
minimize the variance.
So this is a typical
situation where
the mean is pretty
straightforward
and does what you
want, but having
the correct mean does not mean
you've got good answers at all.
And the average
of, you know, like
minus 100 and 100 might be
the correct answer is zero,
but you're way off.
And this measures
how far you are.
So I don't know if
you know these words.
It's unfortunate, but I guess
18.065 can't change it now,
that the variance is
written sigma squared.
And we already have a good use
for the Greek letter sigma,
but today it has a
different use for variance.
And this-- Lagrange multipliers
will come in near the end.
So basically, let
me do a practice
example to recall
what mean and variance
and what those are about.
So let me take a
matrix that's 1 by 2.
So my matrix is just
going to be a b.
OK, I'm going to
sample that twice,
and my rule for the two
samples will be the same.
They will be a identically
distributed, totally identical.
And what's my rule going to be?
So this is like practice.
My rule is going to be I take
that column or that column
with probabilities I have.
And I do it twice.
And I take the average.
So I'm going to take
probabilities are going to be
1/2, 1/2 for the two columns.
And I'm going to do s
equals to 2 samples.
And I'm going to add--
I'll weight them with--
and I'll take the average
of the two samples.
OK.
And that will be my
randomized matrix.
OK, so could we compute
the mean for the--
so I've described a
randomized sampling process.
I've given you the
probabilities, 1/2 and 1/2,
the number of times
I'm going to do it,
and then I divide by
that number of times.
So this is really--
I have a 1 over s here,
because I've got s of these.
And now-- so what are
the possibilities here?
I want to find the mean.
First of all, let's
practice with the mean.
OK, so here are two--
I could think of two different
ways to compute the mean.
Let me start with this one.
What is the mean,
the average value--
mean means average value--
of the first sample?
So the average value of
the first sample, I would--
what is the mean, the general
formula is you add up all
the sample times it's--
the possible samples
times their probabilities.
And in this case,
the probabilities
are 1/2 that the
sample is a, 0 and 1/2
that the sample is 0, b.
So those are my two samples.
And computing the mean
of the total, I get--
but then mean for each sample,
but then I have to multiply,
so let's put what I
got here 1/2 of a, b.
That was the meaning
of each sample,
because my probabilities
were equal, 1/2 and 1/2.
And now, I've got
s equal 2 samples.
So I multiply by 2, and
I get a, b as the mean.
Mean is correct.
Good.
We did the easy one, the mean.
Now, practice with a
variance, or else quit here.
Maybe I should quit
while I'm ahead.
I've got the mean exactly right,
but of course, the samples
might not be right.
So now for the variance.
So what is variance?
Do you remember that?
There are actually two
ways to compute variance.
Let me just remember those over
here and push that board up.
So the variance sigma squared.
Forgive me, if you're
a statistician,
this is like you were
born knowing this.
But the rest of us, we're not.
So the variance is the sum--
one way to do it is add up
the different probabilities
of different things that
could happen of output
minus the mean squared.
So it's the average--
it's the average distance
squared from the mean.
So it takes whatever output
that came with output number
i, minus the mean, which
is the average output.
I square those,
and I get a number.
And that sort of tells me how--
it tells me like in
the famous Gaussian,
if I had a Gaussian
distribution here,
I have a distribution
of 1/2 and 1/2.
So like that maybe
even has a name,
like binomial or something
or Bernoulli or whatever.
But here on this Gaussian
that we all remember,
can I mark what in that
figure where the mean is?
Right in the center.
OK.
Mean.
And what is the variance?
Just to recall what
everybody in the first time
may even hear that
word variance,
what is the variance
kind of measuring?
You're summing squares,
so whether you're
on the right of the
mean or the left
of the mean, no difference,
because you're squaring it.
And it's the distance.
The variance would be sort
of like a typical width.
Maybe I overdid it.
But that would be a
sort of typical sigma.
I'm really just-- since
the words statistics, mean,
and variance haven't
been mentioned in 18.065
until today, I'm just
kind of recalling.
OK, so now I'm prepared
to compute this example.
OK, maybe I'll-- maybe
I'll compute it over here.
OK, so shall I compute the
variance for each sample,
and then I'll multiply by 2,
because I have two samples.
So what are they--
so this is the sigma
squared sample.
Obviously, I could write
down all the possibilities.
Yeah, let me just do the sigma.
So the sample could either
have picked out a, 0 or 0, b.
And the probabilities
were a 1/2.
So I have 1/2 times the
probability times the output.
Let's say the output
is a, 0 minus the mean,
which was a over 2, b over 2.
And I want to square that.
So that was one possibility
when I picked a, 0,
and the other one,
which I'm also
doing with probability
1/2, is in case
I picked 0, b, what was--
you see, I'm not getting
0 for the variance,
because I'm making
an error every time.
I'm never getting the correct
a, 0 or the correct 0,
b, because I'm always doing
this one in the middle.
Now, if I compute all
that, I get a quantity,
and maybe I'll just,
to be on the safe side,
ask your forgiveness.
If I write the answer.
And we could even try
to get the answer, but--
so this is from two samples.
So this is double that one.
I guess I'm bold
enough to try it.
So a, 0, so that would be
minus a over 2 and a b over 2.
I think we got here 1/2 of--
I think-- looks to me like a
over 2 squared plus b over--
I'm missing my plus or minus,
but when I'm squaring them,
that's the whole
point of variance.
Doesn't matter.
And the b over 2.
And here, I think I'm
wrong by a over 2,
and I'm wrong by b over
2 or minus a over 2.
But when I square them
again, doesn't matter.
So I think I get another
1/2 of a over 2 squared
plus b over 2 squared.
Forgive me for this
simple computation,
but just to practice.
So what have I got?
I've got a 1/2 of
that and 1/2 of that.
So that adds up to this
thing a squared over 4
plus b squared over 4, but
then I'm doing two samples.
I have to multiply by
the number of samples.
So I think so times
2 for two samples.
I think I'm getting--
it was 1/4, but now it will
be 1/2 of a squared b squared.
Yeah, I didn't-- yeah, yeah.
I think that's
right, but forgive me
while I just ask myself.
Yeah.
This will be-- actually, you
already have these notes.
This is section 2.4.
So I think it's
there on Stellar.
So what's the point of this?
First point was to like
remember some of the steps that
go into the variance.
Oh, there's another
formula for variance
and I want to tell you.
And the second point is
to bring in a new idea.
Suppose we want to make this--
suppose this variance
is bigger than we want.
Suppose, for example, that
b is a lot bigger than a.
Suppose b is a
lot bigger than a.
Then what should we
have done differently
in this randomized
linear algebra?
If I'm trying to get this thing
close, get close to that thing,
and if b is a lot bigger
than a, then what should
I do differently?
I don't know what b is exactly,
but I have the information
that it's bigger than a.
Then I should increase
the probability--
I shouldn't do half and half.
So here was randomized
sampling taking the average.
My probabilities
were a 1/2 and a 1/2.
I believe that I could
keep the mean correct.
Of course, that's fundamental
to get the mean right.
And get a better answer,
you get a smaller variance
than that b squared over
there by picking that thing
with higher probability.
So that's where the randomized--
it turns out to be called
norm squared probability.
The decision on what the
probability should be goes--
it turns out to be
the optimal one,
goes with the
square of the size.
So if b is twice
as big as a, and I
want to get the variance
down, then the probability--
I should use probabilities
that are four times--
four times as often I
will choose b than a.
That's going to be the
conclusion at 2 o'clock,
hopefully.
OK, so that's one point.
And just another
little point while we
are reviewing variance,
this is the standard formula
for the variance, sum of
all the possible outcomes
with their probabilities, the
distance from the mean squared.
Do you know a second formula,
which is very close to this
and very similar, and it
comes from substituting
the meaning of the mean,
substituting what the mean is?
So yeah, I just want to
mention a second formula.
And I don't know which
one we'll actually use.
But the second formula for the
same quantity, sigma squared,
is the sum of probabilities
times output squared.
So I haven't subtracted off the
mean in this second formula.
I have to do it now.
And I'll do the mean--
I'll do the mean all
at once, mean squared.
Of course, the mean involves--
remember that the mean is
the sum of the probability
times the outcome.
And it's just playing
with a little algebra
to show that you can either--
you have a choice of whatever
is more convenient, subtract
the mean of from each output
or do all the
outputs, but then you
haven't accounted for
the fact that you really
want the distances
from the mean,
and then you subtract
off the mean squared.
Two ways to do it, two
ways, equal ways to do it.
Yeah, we will review the basic
ideas of mean and variance
in the section on probability.
Here, yes, question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the mean
a part of [INAUDIBLE]??
GILBERT STRANG: The mean?
Oh, in here?
That's separate.
Yeah, that's the whole point.
Yeah, so this was like, do
this, and then subtract off
the mean squared.
Or keep the mean in every
term, and do it that way.
Yeah, you could verify
that the two are the same.
OK, so when we go now
to the bigger question,
I've forgotten which way I do
it, but I'm free to choose.
OK, is that like small
sample reasonable,
and you get the
idea that if the--
if we know that if we look
at our matrix, first of all,
and find out which columns are
large, large norm, and which
columns are smaller, then that
might be useful information
to weight our probabilities to
pick the larger one more often.
OK.
In fact, let me just tell you
what are the two possibilities
there.
One is what I just said,
weight your probabilities
by the square of the norm,
this norm squared weighting
that we'll see and take
the columns as they come,
but with higher probability
on the big columns,
or you could say another way
would be mix the columns,
so that they more or
less have similar sizes,
and then, keep track
of what you've done,
and then just the
probabilities can all be equal.
So that would be the other way.
Take your matrix,
mix it up, take
combinations of the columns
with random numbers.
It's a random world here.
Do a mixing, and then
operate on the mixed matrix.
OK, I'm going to do
it the first way.
I'm going to pick these
probabilities to--
they'll turn out to be
proportional to norm squared.
OK, ready for that?
Here it comes.
So let me bring that down.
Yeah.
OK.
Actually, I could
leave it up for now,
because it told us
what we're up to.
OK.
So what have I got?
Let me just see if I can--
so we're multiplying
a times b, and we're
going to use these
probabilities.
Pj is going to be the length
of that column times the length
of that row, norm squared.
Well, norm squared, if I was
multiplying a by a transpose,
then I really would be squaring.
That would be the same as that.
So I'm going to use the word
norm squared or length squared.
Also, here, where the two--
I'm not assuming that
b is a transpose.
OK, so that will be
the probabilities
will be proportional to that.
But now, those that
don't add up to 1, so how
do I make the
probabilities add up to 1?
This is the probability
of choosing column
j of a times times row j of b.
That's what Pj refers to.
OK, so what is my plan?
Oh, I have to make the
probabilities add to 1,
or I'm really breaking
the fundamental law here.
So if I have a bunch
of probabilities,
and I kind of know what I want,
but they don't add up to 1,
what do I do?
Divide by their sum.
Let me call c their sum.
So the probability is
going to be that over c,
and c is going to be the sum of
however many rows and columns.
I guess maybe I had r in my
picture of aj bj transpose.
OK, so all I did was
scale the probability so
that they now add to 1.
Good.
OK, so now I'm
ready to go to work.
I'm ready to choose--
oh, yes, so here's my rule.
I will choose column row
j with this probability,
but then I'm going
to multiply it,
and I'm free to do
that if I want to.
So my approximation, my
approximate AB will be--
I'll take this,
whichever comes out,
I'll take the aj bj
transpose that comes out.
It comes out with
probability Pj.
But I'm going to
divide this by--
and I think I'm, this
is the right one--
s, the number of
samples, times Pj.
So I thought, at
first, that's weird.
Went to all the trouble to
pick these Pj's, claiming
that these are the good ones.
So my claim to eventually
prove at the end--
first, I'll have to understand
how the sampling is done.
That's like the most important.
But then when I go
to compute the mean,
I'll get the correct
mean, and when
I go to compute
the variance, I'll
get some expression
for the variance,
and then the plan will be
choose these Pj's to minimize
that total variance.
So this is what--
that's a typical sample.
With probability Pj, pick
that that matrix, that
rank 1 matrix.
So then my approximate AB
is the sum of all these
over s samples.
Are you with me?
Let me just repeat.
I'm trying to multiply AB.
Each sample is just a
single column times row.
So it's way wrong, way wrong.
It's just a tiny piece of AB.
But I take that sample
with probability Pj,
and I divide it by S Pj, so
that the Pj's cancel here.
Oh, yes.
OK, right.
So I would like to see
that the mean is correct.
I would like to see that
the mean is correct.
I'm going to compute
the mean of my process.
So like it's falling
into my lap here.
I made it that way.
These Pj's cancel.
I divided by s.
So the mean of a
typical sample will be--
so the mean of one
sample is the probability
of getting it times what I take.
So it's just the sum of
aj bj transpose over s.
You're going to say, OK,
you're wasting our time.
But we got--
I would just want
to show that I'm
getting the correct
mean out of this plan.
So do you see that if
that's a mean of one sample,
so what's the mean of the
sum of all the samples?
Well, multiply by s, because
it was the same mean.
Every sample had
the same mean, just
as it did in our Little
League practice example.
So that's the mean
of one sample.
So the mean of all samples added
together, multiplies this by s.
The s's cancel, and I get AB.
Remembering my-- however way
I defined AB there, yeah.
Yeah.
All I'm saying here is that
I did something reasonable
in the sampling process, so
that the mean came out right.
And now is the hard
part, the variance.
What's the variance?
OK, so what do I
have to compute--
and I may-- it will depend on
the p's, p1 to pr, I guess.
We had r different rows,
different column row
pairs to choose, and we chose
probabilities, these guys,
that depended on this size.
And now I'm going to
compute the variance,
and it won't be 0, because
every sample is wrong.
I'm never getting from a sample.
A sample is just giving me a
column times a row, a rank 1
guy, and they averaged out
to give the correct product.
But each one is certainly wrong,
because it's just a rank 1.
So when I compute variance, I'm
going to definitely not get 0,
right?
In other words, of course,
when would the variance be 0?
Yeah, if AB were rank 1, I guess
I'd get it right every time.
Thanks.
That was a better answer
than I had in mind.
Yeah, yeah.
The variance would only be
0 if every sample was right.
And that would be true
if the rank was 1,
and there was only
one thing to choose.
But that's not the
problem we want.
OK, so the variance is there.
My instinct is to tell you
what this calculation produces,
since you and I can read.
Would you allow me to do that?
So here, the variance
for a sample turned out
to equal, so we
will figure it out,
turns out to equal
the sum over--
as it was up there of the aj
bj transpose, probably squared.
Let me just check.
Yes, squared.
Yeah, why don't I
help myself here?
So these are squared because
variances are squared.
And then when I
look to see what--
I think there is an s
there, and there's a Pj,
so why is there a Pj there,
when it canceled here?
So here, the Pj, when I
multiply by that, canceled.
Why doesn't it
cancel over there?
Because it's squared over there.
Over there, this
thing is squared.
So it was Pj twice.
Here, I have Pj, its
probability once.
So I've still got the Pj in the
denominator, one factor of Pj
in the denominator.
And then-- so that is--
I guess what I'm
doing is I'm computing
the variance this way.
So what I've computed
now is this first bit,
and then I said should
subtract the mean squared.
And this is for one sample.
So the mean squared is--
I think it turns out to be
1 over s times AB squared
in this Frobenius norm.
It's a squared plus b squared
stuff that I saw before.
OK, so this--
I've jumped a serious
step to get from the sum--
the formula for the variance.
I've plugged in this
problem and got that.
OK, and now I'm going to sample.
Let's see where-- yeah.
I would like to simplify this.
I would like to simplify that.
So I have to plug in the Pj's.
OK, so after plug
in for that Pj,
and we decided what Pj
was going to be here.
OK, so when I plug that
in in the denominator,
it will cancel one of these.
And I'll just have a sum
of of aj Pj bj norms.
And what that is C.
So let me say this again just.
It's something you can just
check when you have a minute.
When I plug in that value for
Pj here, it cancels the squares
and just leaves the first power.
So then I'm adding up the
first power, and I get C.
But the Pj had a factor
C in the denominator,
and it's in the denominator over
there, so that C is up there.
So it's C squared coming
here, a constant squared,
minus the other term.
There's a 1 over s.
That will eventually go away.
And this other term
is 1 over s norm
AB the Fromenius norm squared.
Or maybe 1 over s's are--
so you're seeing-- and I
apologize, a little bit messy
bit of algebra.
A little bit messy
But that's what
we ended up with.
And when we take s
samples and combine them,
that will cancel
the s, and I think
it'll knock that out when
we combine the s samples.
OK.
Now what?
Now, we get to choose
those probabilities.
And how are we going
to choose them?
What will be the best choice?
Here is the expression
for the variance.
Yeah, this is good.
This is good.
Stay with me for now, and you
will be saying to yourself,
there's some steps there
that I didn't see fully,
and I want to check.
And I agree.
But let me say that
we get to that point,
and this is a fixed number.
So it's C that we would
like to make small,
and that's our final job.
This was true for any choice of
the probabilities P. Well, oh,
yeah, sorry.
Yeah, yeah.
So I want to--
this still had in
it a probability.
Yeah.
What do I want to do?
I want to show that that was
the best choice, that this
was the best choice.
Yeah, yeah.
I want to show that
that's the best
choice, that the choice of
weights of probabilities, based
on length of a times the length
of b-- of course, it sounds
reasonable, doesn't it?
We want to-- for big
columns and big rows,
we want to have a higher
probability to choose those.
But is the probability
proportional
to the length of
both, or should it
be proportional to the 10th
power or the square root
or what?
That's what our final
step of optimizing the P.
So this is the final step.
Optimize the
probabilities, P1 to P2,
I guess, no, P1 to Pr, for the r
rows, r columns of a and r rows
of b, subject to--
they have to add up to 1.
And what do I mean by optimize?
I mean minimize.
This optimize means
minimizing this expression,
C. So aj bj transpose.
Where is-- over Pj.
Oh yeah, wait a minute.
Help.
So let me just see.
Yeah, my variance
has got a Pj in it.
Yeah, my variance-- sorry--
my variance-- oh, OK.
This is my variance.
This is the result if I make
the right choice for the--
if I make this choice
for the probabilities.
But I'm backing up a minute.
This is if-- this is the
with optimal Pj's, then
we got that answer.
Great.
That was our answer.
But I'm backing up
to this and saying,
what are the optimal Pj's
to make this variance small?
So really, I'm just doing this.
Let me write the
problem simpler.
Minimize with the sum
of the P's equal 1,
some quantity Q squared
over Qj over Pj.
Yeah, that's it.
How do you-- so these Qj's that
I just introduced that letter
for are the aj bj's.
They're given.
Maybe I'll just put back aj Pj.
So to repeat, this is the
calculation of the variance
for any choice of Pj's.
This is what I get if
I make the best choice,
but over here, I'm going
to show that it is the best
choice, that it's the choice
that makes this result as
small as possible.
So that's the Lagrange
multiplier aspect.
So the statistics has been done.
I'm getting this answer.
And instead of putting
in some weird Q,
let me put in what these are.
They're whatever.
They're a bunch of numbers.
But I'm dividing by the Pj, and
how do you find the best Pj?
Do you know about that
optimization question?
They have to add to 1.
And the Lagrange
had the great idea.
So this is maybe the first
time we've used his idea.
So do you remember
what his idea is?
He takes this constraint, and
he builds it into the function.
He multiplies it by some unknown
mysterious number, often called
lambda, but nothing to
do with eigenvalues,
of the constraints that
the Pi's should add to 1.
So he had 0.
He had 0, but with
a variable lambda.
This is Lagrange's idea.
So it's pretty neat
that this problem--
I've left randomized sampling.
I've arrived at this
final sub problem,
optimizing the probabilities
under the condition
that they add to 1,
and Lagrange's idea
was build that equation
into the function.
Then you can take
derivatives, but you also
take derivatives with
respect to lambda,
because that's now an unknown.
And you solve-- you set
the derivatives to 0,
and you get the answer.
It's like a miracle.
But if you've seen Lagrange,
it's a confusing miracle.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
OK.
So if I take the derivatives
with respect to the P's, set
them to 0, I think I'm going
to get the recommended P's.
So I've computed the final
answer with a recommended P's,
but now I'm going to show that
they really are recommended.
So can you take the derivative
of that with respect to P?
Can I-- I'll just raise this a
little, raise it a little more.
OK, take the
derivative with respect
to P, each P, because
I've got n unknowns there,
or however many,
maybe r unknowns.
And I've got lambda, so
I've got r plus 1 things.
So what's the derivative with
respect to P. OK, calculus.
Take the derivative of that.
It's aj bj transpose over--
with a minus Pj squared, right?
And the derivative of that
with respect to Pj is?
Minus lambda.
So that derivative with
respect to Pj is 0,
and the derivative-- so this was
a derivative with respect to Pj
has to be 0.
And then the derivative
with respect to lambda--
the derivative with
respect to lambda is that,
on call them j's--
j's minus equals 1.
Lagrange confused
the whole world,
but he gave us a break that
in the derivative with respect
to lambda, it just brings
back that constraint,
because he just built it in
with the factor of lambda,
then he took the derivative,
and it brought back
that constraint.
But this part is
the beautiful part.
Now, what do I learn from that?
And sometimes this
would be a plus.
Why don't I make it a plus
just to make my life easier?
Lagrange is dead now,
and he don't care anyway,
whether it's plus or a minus.
OK.
So this is telling me this.
So this is tell me
what its multiplier is.
He's telling me that--
this equation is telling me
that the multiplier is aj bj
transpose over Pj squared.
Or put it another way, he's
telling me that Pj squared is--
I guess, I'm hoping that after
the pretty confusing steps
that we took, this is a
separate little bit of math,
using the Lagrange
multiplier idea,
and I hope that your
thought will be,
boy, that was pretty simple.
So I'm going to put
the Pj squareds here
and the lambda there.
What does this tell me?
I've taken the derivative with
respect to the Pj's, and I got
this equation for each j
because I took the derivative,
the partial derivative with
respect to each of the Pj's.
And it tells me
that Pj squared--
wait a minute.
What's the square in there for?
Help.
I've only got two minutes.
And oh, they have to add to 1.
Oh yeah, lambda is
going to save us.
Right, lambda is
going to save us,
because the total
probabilities-- so Pj
will be the square
root of this stuff.
And then I-- the number
lambda, I haven't decided.
Lagrange's multiplier,
I haven't decided.
So what is it?
It's the correct number
to make this equal to 1.
So that is the C. Oh god.
Why have I got
square root there?
Shoot.
AUDIENCE: I think
you're supposed
to start off with squares.
GILBERT STRANG: I should
have started with squares?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: So
these should be squares?
Ah, thank you.
You could have told me earlier.
When you see a
professor in trouble,
don't just let him hang there.
OK, all right.
OK, and this is aj bj transpose.
So apart from the
kerfuffle here,
and the notes get
it right, because I
had time to think
there, it turns out
that this optimum gave
the formula for the Pj's
that I used earlier.
So when I introduced
this formula,
I said, let's choose
those probabilities,
but then I came
back at the very end
and showed that they are
the probabilities that
minimize the variance.
So that's like today's lecture.
Can you just think
a minute, but please
do go back through the
notes, because there
is some messy steps
in the variance
there that I had
to go by quickly.
But you understand the
principle, that we set up
a randomized system.
We choose probabilities, aiming
to get the smallest variance.
And it turns out that the
good probabilities are bigger
when the column is a larger
column, so that to use this,
you have to go
through the matrix
and find the length
of the columns,
because that's what's telling
you the probabilities.
So that's like a
first pass through.
Before you do the
randomized sampling,
you must decide on
the probabilities,
and they depend on the sizes
of the different columns.
Thank you for getting
me through that.
I'll come back to a little
more about randomized things
next time, and then later, not
much later, but a little bit
later, we'll be seeing
probability much more
seriously OK, thank you.